foreign
[Music]
was an Avenger
before I got this family
I mean mistakes
choosing between what the world wants
you to be
and who you are
[Music]
we have to go back to where it all
started
where did you think I was all this time
unfinished business
[Music]
I'm sorry we had our orders and we
played our role it wasn't real
it was real to me
to me
you were everything
[Music]
[Music]
one thing's for sure
I'm done running from my past
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
throughout my life
the ten Rings gave our family power
if you wanted them to be yours one day
you have to show me you are strong
enough to carry them
you are a product of all who came before
you
the legacy of your family
you are your mother and whether you like
it or not
you are also your father
I told my men
I wouldn't be able to kill you if they
try
foreign
[Music]
my son
you can't run from your past
[Applause]
is this what you wanted
you got this
thank you
oh
five years ago Thanos erased half of the
population of the universe
but the people of this planet brought
everyone back with a slap of a finger
sudden Return of the population
provided the necessary energy
with the emerges to begin
foreign
how long do we have
seven days
[Music]
we're eternals
we came here seven thousand years ago
[Music]
two minutes from the deviants
[Music]
why didn't you guys help fight Thanos or
any War all the other terrible things
throughout history
we're instructed not to interfere in any
human conflicts unless deviants are
involved
[Music]
we need to find the others
I haven't seen some of them for
centuries
I hello
this is what the end of the world looks
like it must be a front row seat you
know what's never saved the planet your
sarcasm
[Music]
we have loved these people since the day
we arrived
when you love something
you protect it
[Applause]
you can't protect
any of them
[Music]
I pay for the perfect Safe House well
what's this even made of vibranium
fall collection
Ikea
[Music]
ever since I got bit by that spider
we had one week
where my life is felt normal
that was when you found out
[Music]
when you botched that spell where you
wanted everyone to forget the Peter
Parker Spider-Man
we started getting some visitors
[Applause]
from every universe
hello Peter
you're not Peter Parker
I'm sorry what was your name again Dr
Otto Octavius
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
there are others out there we need to
send them back so Scooby-Doo this crap
you know oh this is kind of your mess I
know a couple magic words myself
starting with the word please
Scooby-Doo this crap
flying out into the darkness
fight ghosts what do you mean they all
die fighting Spider-Man it's their fate
sorry kid
yeah me too don't
look there has to be another win
their danger to our universe
you're not gonna take this away from me
Peter
you're struggling
damn everything you want while the world
tries to make you choose
is all my fault I can't save everyone
[Applause]
what's happening they're starting to
come through and I can't stop them
December 17th exclusively in movie
theaters tickets on sale November 29th
spider Monday
someone once told me
that the reality I thought I knew
was just one
of many
be careful which path you travel down
stronger than you have left their way
you think there will be no consequences
we're in the end game now
is sacrificed everything
and it but nothing
oh strange what have you done
I never meant for this to happen
you cannot control everything
you brought this on yourself
[Music]
you break the rules and become a hero
I do it and I become the enemy
sensing thing
people are some Madness really pd-13 to
be the first to see the mind-bending
phenomena in premium large format in
IMAX tomorrow
do I once used for battle
now they're about humble tools for peace
I need to figure out
exactly who I am
[Music]
going to choose my own path live in the
moment
[Music]
my superhero in days are over
[Music]
[Music]
remember what I told you
you ever feel lost just look into the
eyes of the people that you love
[Music]
me
what just listening
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
coming
for the surface world
you know what you whisper
ing
foreign
[Music]